voy a tarde buenas tardes a todos a
primera cosa que me pregunte cuando me
hicieron no con vídeos alumnos me
convidaron para falar fue en que lingua
euri a falar se uniría a falar en
español o iría a falar en portugués o
iría a falar un portugués fronterizo
entonces decidí que vos falar un poco en
español o un poco portugués y también
portugués fronterizo porque e hizo o que
me identifica a segunda pregunta que me
fui y soy que tema que huiría falar
soy profesora mucho tiempo muy de usanos
rafale de muchas cosas hay su tema que
voy a hablar hoy aquí la verdad que la
primera vez que un falo y un tema que me
toca mucho moción aumente porque o bufa
lar a ver si consigo pasar aquí
de esa peso va ahí esa persona que
ustedes ven ahí soy el cuando nací lucía
bosé ellas desde que nací continúe
teniendo
continúo ahí y porque tuvo falar de mí
que puede tocar a voces que usa le da
mía historia la verdad si yo no quiero
que posees aprendan tanto sobre mí a
vida sino que quiero que voces aprendan
sobre las personas que cruzaron mía vida
que cruzaron mía vida argentina más
también que cruzaron mía vida aquí no
brasil y uruguay o que hizo puede
inspirar no apenas a voces sino también
a mis alumnos a mis futuros alumnos a
conseguir transformar un
aún así aquí pocas personas saben muy
pocas esta ciudad si se llama los
molinos y fijan interior de argentina
pertino de rosario esta ciudad system
2.000 habitantes cada vez que falla aquí
no brasil siempre me preguntan 200 mil
tíos pero no dos mil en una ciudad si
todo el mundo sabe la vida de todo el
mundo salir para estudiar salir para
morar en otro país es un acontecimiento
mundial
tipo una celebridad si yo crecí aquí
el fish o encino infantil ahí la persona
que posee es buena foto
y me ama
me ama ya mujer más inspiradora que un
con eso
hoy si me ama ya está con una dolencia y
enfrenta fronteras más dura que
podríamos enfrentar que a frontera dador
es una frontera que me separan la mía
familia y que tal vez esa frontera y
multa hasta que nos vivimos esa frontera
muchas de que viven también los alumnos
que explicarlo en sí de su familia
me ama y porque os vale que la mujer más
inspiradora que yo con eso porque desde
pequeña me ama a mí si no se va a perder
todo en esta vida no se va a perder la
fe bosch se va a perder o amor voz se va
a perder esperanza maestra en una cosa
que posee no va a perder que o
conocimiento y me ama y repetía tanto
más tanto hizo que un aprendiz o
múltiple y office vecino primario una
única escuela que tenacidad sí
el fish o ensino me dio una única scola
tenacidad y pela fotos para ustedes
pueden descubrir más o menos cuántos
años que estén yo
edad para percibir que éstas de cada
década
y cuando estaba no ensino me dio
al finalizar el día que decidir
ubicaban a mi ciudad y trabajando
un día para rosario que fija a 90
kilómetros de la ciudad porque en
rosario a cidade más expertos piden la
universidad pública
le pregunté para miami y ella me falou
rafale para vos que un único que se
bailaba siempre na súa vida el
conocimiento
ayew quería estar tú tú yo comencé
primero relaciones internacionales
medicina ciencias políticas y ahí yo
llegué
a universidad nacional de rosario
aprender letras cuando estaba en un
final de carrera
una profesora
cruz me cruzo y me hallo jorgelina tiene
una bolsa de estudio para estudiar para
hacer un intercambio la universidad
federal de san carlos en brasil igual
que usted debería tentar esa bolsa y
coleando para el ife le ole aguas o
también maíz 13 yo como ir
no temía mynott en cómo me sustentar en
toda mi carrera estudiando y trabajando
ahí él a mí sólo pon conversa con su
familia fui falar con mi mamá
y mi mamá me falló igual que usted en
más de una línea pasaporte final nunca
china ha ido del país
y uno tiene también ni siquiera una mala
porque no viajábamos porque queríamos
termal a la mía casa
eu fish antón esa selección yo concurrí
a la bolsa de estudios para estudiar en
san carlos
yo gané
cuando gane esa bolsa
el feef astaire o pasaporte en buenos
aires mis dos hermanos hicieron una una
mala con una sacó la de supermercado
sólo se sacó la que le vamos para esas
de plástico grande del supermercado
ahí colocaron una madera en bajas y
cuatro ruedas para poder cargar mis
hermanos no terminaron si no me dio por
él son unas las dos pechugas que con eso
con los mayores saberes
cuando llegué en san carlos
primero en san paulo narrado diaria y
aún no conocía un idioma y un chino que
llegar a estancar los enfrentan a tirar
a pasaje para estancar los yo pregunté
quiero un pasaje para san carlos hay un
señor óleo para mí y falo corredor se
anhela que volando para el tipo
no entendí nada porque en español el
pasillo y ventana
él y percibió muy rápidamente y él y tal
vez no salva más el ife para mí en un
papel un diseño dúo ni bus con un
corredor con a gianella y él y tal vez
no salva que tengo este papel hasta hoy
si ese pequeño gesto que él y face me
permitió no sólo escoger corredores
anhela sino también llegar a san carlos
cuando iba para johnny bus
a entrar nuevos en argentina muy común
que cuando alguien te ayuda a cargar
amarla y colocar en bayonne únicos pose
de una brocheta propina en español ayuda
y ello l ahora mismo no no no
propina porque ofrece una propina y le
propinan al crédito no querer propina y
él me tendí nada sinceramente más de un
mes y ahí no terminó de salir me subí no
ánimos y en brasil
es muy común
efe será portado entre un motorista los
pasajeros en argentina no cuando el
espejo aporta primera cosa que vence fue
no sap no hubo vuelta apremia cast él
iba y me levanté hoy
eso fue con mucho miedo hasta san carlos
y cuando vi a universidad de san carlos
que el african estrada él comenzaba te
aporta del motorista ayudándome quiero
bajarme quiero bajar y el irme para
espera espera pero hay planos pero hay
no es la única cosa que un miembro tiene
parón o medio de estrada tiró me ama la
bolsa que me firmó en facebook y me falo
poseemos loca mismo y aunque no entendía
nada vale o privada y continué
cuando llegue en san carlos y hoy llegué
a la universidad si ninguén también me
entendía nada todo el mundo sabe que yo
estaba viendo por un congreso que estaba
lindo para algún lugar mining en
entendía que falaba hasta que llegó la
profesora de español su departamento de
letras del fiscal
tal vez no consiga pasar aquí como me
emocioné cuando escuché esa beso a falar
la mía lingua
maíz fue una emoción de pelo - su voz
entendida pero menos vamos a comprender
yo conviví con estas personas que vos te
ven aquí en una residencia universitaria
ellis mencionaron a falar o portugués
con su touch vais a fallar un portugués
cuando estaba terminando mi a bolsa de
estudio la profesora de portugués la
universidad será de san carlos
me falo jorgelina josette en que tentar
a maestría la universidad se estan paulo
fue leo la profesora cuando termine mi a
bolsa en un bote cómo explicar aquí
porque mi familia no te ven como me
sustentar el falo tipos de files un
proceso selectivo y posee aprobada
el power pasión para bosé y de i volta
de san carlos san pablo para vos de
cursar las disciplinas y cuando vos te
tengo primero entregó 2 m de golpe
y su proceso selectivo el pase el tibio
primero emprego
aquí en san paulo y obre volví para el
san paulo también me enseñó que una
ciudad si muchos insa en una ciudad sin
multitudes igual más también puede ser
una ciudad mucho goleadora
cuando estabas tan paulo
el que sí que sería hoy un marido que le
debe estar por ahí
él me elevo
avn horizonte
en belo horizonte él trabaja en un
centro federal tecnológico en esta fecha
de minas gerais
esos alumnos yo siempre faltaba para él
y quiero que les lambré ellis
mencionaron mucho más lo que el cine
para él es el y mencionaron que no es
sino medio es posible transformar
educación que no es sino medio es
posible transformar nuestros odios
cuando estaba en el horizonte sigue tres
años
es decidir para uno de éste
porque usted decidió ir para un orden
este podéis preguntar por qué ejecutaba
muchas cosas sobre un orden este yo
quería conocer cómo era un nordeste una
verdad si en un orden o convivir con
muchas culturas trabajé también durante
muchos años yo conocí un orden externo
aquel que me era salado sino con ese
honor de este cálido acogedor oye para
mí una lembranza muy bonita él y también
me dieron mucha fuerza las personas que
cruzaron los caminos
para llegar aquí a foz iguazú y para
llegar a un hilo y aquí yo aprendí sobre
la diversidad sobre empatía y sobrevivir
entre lenguas
esta es una aula de español
esos alumnos mencionaron también en aula
no es un espacio pesado a aula también
puede ser un espacio abierto esos
alumnos mencionan todos los días sobre
la cultura de ellis llegó a crédito que
educación y un mundo puede transformar
si conocemos mejor u otro para nos
conocer mejor a los mismos
esas personas que voces ven ahí que son
mis colegas me signaron que ellis no
apenas quieren aprender una lengua para
se comunicar con un otro
ellos quieren aprender una lengua para
conocer mejor u otro y para así conocer
mejor a ellos mismos aún y la medicina
hizo todos los días
foz iguazú también
estas personas son alumnos de medicina
fui profesora del ies 'el y mencionaron
también la medicina de su lado social
ellis mencionaron también sobre empatía
y al mensaje que yo quiero dejar para
ustedes
esas son las profesoras de tu municipio
de la red de municipal de foz de iguazú
el mensaje que yo quiero dejar para vos
es esta empatía no apenas nos colocar un
lugar de otro la empatía es saber
escuchar u otro la empatía no tienen que
ver con ayuda a empatía empatía tiene
que ver con poder transformar la vida de
otro
yo quería dejar por último un mensaje
para ustedes y que podamos ser empáticos
no apenas con aquellos que nos
consideramos iguales que podamos ser
empáticos con aquel y que nos
consideramos diferentes porque en la
diferencia que nos somos diversos o
brigadas
[Música]